yo
bootleg cat podcast black zach in here
south carolina's own um zach
first of all let's talk about all the
jewelry you got on bro yeah
that's a lot my g you got the i just see
you got the custom band on there with
your name on in this shot i never saw
that
yeah um so ariana he he made this like
from scratch like
he got a dm me in the dial is that a
rolex yeah it's a real legacy cousin
i played like 124 i probably overpaid
for it but
i just want to be the first one with
some [ __ ] like that that's a hundred and
twenty thousand dollar watch 120
damn what's up what about the other one
something lighter yeah my brother my
brother brought this for me for my
birthday
he brought us from i think it's like
this is jubilee it's like 30
something like that man your brother's a
nice guy
yeah for so yeah and then obviously you
got every i mean how many chains you got
on bro
oh i only got like three i ain't really
like when i travel i already like
bringing all my jerks
that's very smart yeah i'm like bringing
all this [ __ ] because this
would be too much of a hassle if you had
to estimate
how much money you have invested in
jewelry
what would be your estimation like 750
800 000 do you look at jewelry as an
investment
um at first i was just i ain't even
gonna lie to you i was just doing it
because at first i seen like
but this before like i all the rappers
was really really
getting into i mean i used to see like
the the amigos and [ __ ] all the time
like they'll
be at the jury store and i'm like damn
this is what the rapper's about to get
into like jerry so i just started buying
it
like but then as i learned it i had to
learn like
watches is what keep value watches and
cuban links and [ __ ] like that so i was
like man i'm about to just start
buying like watches and cuban links and
stuff like that
i heard that if you flood your watch
though it takes away from
the long-term value is that true yeah it
do take away for for
for some watches but right now like how
to
how to like how the pandemic and stuff
is from what the jewel is telling me
like he be trying to buy my ap
from me you be trying to buy it back
yeah he was trying to buy back just for
saying like
everything loan everything right now oh
wow
that's crazy you know it's interesting
because we're in a a point in time in
in the world where there's people out
here that are real desperate
to hit a lick does that make you you
just said that you don't move around a
lot when when you travel with all your
jewelry
are you worried about like you know
being out of state or being out of town
and like you know
[ __ ] in texas benny got shot boozy got
shot you know yeah 2020 but craig
it's been crazy are you like does that
make you change the way you move around
because you're kind of known to have
a lot of joy that's kind of like a you
know thing a lot of people know has that
has that made you reevaluate that at all
i mean i feel like nobody untouchable
but i just feel like
you know it's all about like what you're
going to do after your [ __ ] get took or
something like
anybody can get some jerry took or
somebody you gotta just handle it how i
come
and you gotta know how to move like i
don't be in places around got no
business or
wow why i shouldn't be there at the time
so
have you ever had any sort of incident
happen like that where maybe someone
tried to catch you slipping
never no not gonna work yeah yeah we're
not gonna work